bam God that really stung hello and
welcome to the lobby gam spots weekly
hang out every Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific
Time right here on gamespot.com I'm your
host Dani DWI delighted as ever to be
joined by Christopher Waters hey Danny
hey to go oh man you doing all right yes
you know who's in the house though I'm
torn about today's show why you torn
because the USA's no nothing nothing
else is happening nothing happen I'm
torn because it's been so long Alex new
house has been here as our news intern
for a while and it's the first time we
had him on the show I know yeah who's in
the house Alex new house or is going to
referr to you for the rest of the show
Alex the intern yes how are you doing
sir I'm great how are you I'm great I
got one question to ask you how many
German testicles have you made explode
this week hundreds hundreds really play
a lot how many can you do this morning
hopefully three okay we're going to do
it we're going to do the three nutshot
challenge we got a bunch more games on
today's show we got the New World of
Warcraft expansion pack uh Warlords of
dror is it Warlords of dror I just play
w a lot that's on the show later we got
beta access to that and you can also win
beta access we're giving away a hell
bunch of keys but I'm not going to tell
you right now I'm going to just dangle
out there like a pair of German
testicles just waiting to waiting to get
sniped also Divinity original sin but
let's talk about that later right now
it's time to explode some uh World War
II testicles Alex with Sniper elas 3 not
actually called sniper elas version
three uh it's called V3 in Europe it is
yeah yeah North America can't handle it
was sniper lead V to now not so much uh
as we can see here Alex is already not
sniping someone no how much of this game
cuz you've played a bunch of this both
you guys have actually uh Alex first of
all with you H how much of this game is
this close quarter is kind of stealthy
stuff um as much as you want really um I
do a lot of sniping I did a lot of
sniping when I was playing this
yesterday and uh but I mean you can
sneak through and knife everyone if you
want um some people you have to snipe or
shoot but uh there is quite a bit of it
if you choose to play that route so have
you been picking to sniping because you
just prefer the sniping or is the
stealth stuff not good um the stealth
the stealth stuff like that running up
and knifing someone is okay um it's the
same animation every time but I'm going
to kill this guy real quick kill him
kill him what what call your organs I'm
saying lung I'm saying stomach I'm going
to go oh oh that was a liver I think
that was
everything and you also and that was
head is burning off all right nicely
done let's get that guy uh so yeah
Sniper Elite obviously known for these
kind of uh slow motion bullet
porn internal organ destroying
shots uh the one we of course were
enforcing earlier you can blow off man's
test oh my God or like fragment the
skull vers V2 is really good uh but they
they definitely seem to be leaning more
into it this year but with
like the orans cuz it was just bones
predominantly anyway wasn't it bones
will shatter and like fragments there's
a model for that organs sometimes will
like burst or something like that but
mostly it's just blood like they don't
deform too much in the way that bones do
so even though it is tempting to make
every shot a nutshot yeah uh it you also
want to go for bones sometimes because
they shatter in Gross WS I always go for
bones yeah so um why I'm staying right
here is because there's a generator
behind me that's making noise masking my
shots every so every so often so I'm
going to hang out up here for a bit and
yeah chill out man pick up pick
out can you snip a man's enough when
he's sitting down oh no too early okay
now that got it what do you think is it
going to be what what the hell did you
um you did it you did it real
good so sometimes you can snipe like
grenades if they're on the belt of the
guys oh very so that could have happened
that's cool uh there could have been I
think there could have been some kind of
tank of fuel in that tent but you know
that was interesting I want to let all
the folks at home know as well if you've
got any questions in the twitch chat or
in the Gamespot comments or Gamespot
chat uh feel free to throw them in there
just stick a big old question in capital
beforehand and the guys uh we'll we'll
get them add to us here on the on the on
the stage what are you doing here you
got some tutorial stuff just learning
about the sort of stealth mechanic right
like yes on screen right now you have
this little eyeball that shows your
visibility but once you're like once
they hear a noise it goes into this
whole other tiered system of like uh
stealth discoverability oh he jumped
over the nut protector AKA wall oh oh
wow incapacitate that's horrible have
you like like is he going to be a
wheelchair in there or something no so
what yeah like you basically shattered
his pelvis but you can actually if you
look like keep an eye on him yeah he can
be revived so you can do that like super
nasty sniper thing of like incapacitate
a dude to draw out other guys and then
snipe them I forget what movie that
was Private Ryan was a that's how Vin
Diesel got Gap that his first ever movie
really yeah yeah Spielberg saw his Pilot
anyway you've not destroyed one testicle
yet I haven't I'm working on it Danny
you need to up your testicle let me see
if I can get this guy I can't go to
sleep unless I see some testicles
exploding so you better oh yeah God got
it that I capacitate you all right
yeah well not then so now you've got
this extra glowing meter on the right
side of sort of the the bottom right
side of the radar Circle yeah and it'll
basically cool down as people search for
you and as you get away from sight and
so Alex we were talking earlier and you
know you were mentioning you can do it
you know you can go full stealth you can
actually kind of just like crazy snipe
your way through and if anyone gets
close try to you know silence them or
them what has been your preferred play
style so far sort what have you found
yourself gravitating towards um I really
like sneaking up behind them and shoting
him in the head with the silence pistol
I find that the most satisfying um like
if I can do it right here like that just
such a such a satisfying king um I also
not the biggest fan of the gore um oh
yeah yeah so I tend to stick more
towards the silence Crystal which is
think it's a bit too much might be a
little bit too much yeah hey Chris I got
a question here from the chat yellow
Sanchez says can you obtain a domino
effect kill streak from one shot have
you seen that uh where like the bullet
goes through multiple dudes I was trying
to do that in a now playing that Sean
and I did I was not able to but I I
remember being able to do that in V2 I
did I did it too a couple times I did it
with three people
actually yeah did you get three nut
shots cuz if you don't do that in the
next like eight minutes you're fired bro
you got to you got to oh don't there
watch watch He's presenting do it now no
just he's he's incapacitated someone's
going to come and help him up it doesn't
you got to go you got to at least
finish wait for someone to come and then
shoot them in do you know how big oh
that's it that's it he do you know how
big German testicles are like I've seen
a lot have you yeah just by watching
like the World Cup sure got kill he died
isolated ghost what do that mean that he
was alone and I did it without and now
he's a ghost is he haunting you yes yeah
just test off with this testicles haunt
you for the rest of the game for every
ghost experience bonus you get you uh
you get another ghost following you and
haunting your Eternal
Soul uh VY asks can you turn on slowmo
for all shots have you seen anything
like that Alex um you can turn it on for
any kill shot with a sniper rifle okay
um anything else it just doesn't doesn't
play yeah you're not going to get SMG or
silen pistol stuff uh but yeah you can
you can't adjust how frequently it
happens like there you can like choose
increased or normal or like no x-ray
there's a few more options in3 here we
go here we
go keep your job at Game Spot no my good
no just not wanting me to get that
nutshot I believe in you we are going to
have to get have a lesson on German male
anatomy apparently while you're doing
that sleep sleeping guy in that tent oh
yeah I think he's dead oh he might be
dead did you kill him
natural causes lot of a lot of people in
the North African wars raml just waited
and they just died of natural causes
yeah nle legs on Twitch asks how is the
length of the game does the slow-mo
bullet stuff get annoying throughout it
Alex you've played a bun you played like
good five six hours of this right just
not want of me
to oh here we go I don't know is he
going to get lucky with the Crouch no
wait oh so close
ohib more zoom if you want Push Up on
the d-pad get nice get that nice bull
shot um well anyways as um what's his
name was asking yes um it it is the same
sort of bullet cam every single time you
do it so I did find that it did get bit
a bit old after a while so you can just
press A and Skip it if you wanted to to
pick up the pace or whatever at that
stage is the game still fun like what
just like what do you think about this
have you enjoyed playing it like is it
something that's worth picking up um if
you're really into stealth games like
this I think that it's pretty good um
it's I I mean the the AI isn't the best
ever they stay on you know strict paths
and they just go straight back to doing
their own thing even if they find a body
um really yeah okay nothing's really
change if you just wait it out for a bit
Yeah they kind of do like they get that
those alert that there's a yellow circle
on there so they'll be alerted and
they'll kind of search the nearby area
but you know I mean they're not too
tenacious although there are what there
are there are different difficulty
sliders do you know if that that affects
their kind of awareness um it does it
does affect their awareness I think the
alert timer lasts longer they're more um
aware of things going on around them is
there anyone left in this map to to
murder beert there's like dozens yeah
all right well time is not your friend
at the moment wait for it to get small I
think if you wait for this zoom in CHR
thinks he can do it wait for it to get a
little smaller aim small Miss small
right I don't know what that anx got
under enough pressure right now there's
a guy right up on that bridge through
that bush is there yeah oh well he's not
going to be our intern anymore if if
unless he gets three nut shots in like
and by three nut shots I mean I want six
balls here you never you never double
okay I at least I have never seen that I
don't know okay so three balls Alex may
have seen something three balls I don't
want an extra ball I'd be happy with
with like a set then I guess that was
was a nice head shot where do you think
German people's testicles are Alex in
their heads
apparently somewhere in the head
region let's try to get somewhere here
we go I believe in you while you're
doing Nash more questions Hass asks
about the multiplayer have you guys
played any of it negative I couldn't get
into any games besides one One V one
yesterday um I mean it's basically the
same as single player except you have
another guy stalking you I think the
game is out today yeah so it's not we
haven't had too much experience right
with there is co-op in this as well as
well I saw I saw in the menu I thought I
saw Cooperative I haven't checked that
out it would be good to cover my six
with a trap it would cover your six with
a Trap full of German testicles this
Barrel looks
dangerous yeah observations about my
environment voice acting huh how's the
voice acting in this game Alex not
really a
fan yeah you know where you could have
stuck that knife and it and his
testicles yeah all right all right here
we go right let's you got like three or
four minutes here got a good sniper per
here yeah
ooh take your time okay just really line
it up wait until like the your breath is
like totally empty zo right in just Zen
the tiniest red spot NOP too high too
high little lower you can zoom in a bit
moread go do it okay all right take wait
for your shot wait for your shot there's
an art to taking a man's twig and
berries right there you think yeah I
think that was oh
incapacitated my goodness that was such
a close
call you almost hit his testicles
relocated the biscuit almost went into
the basket biscuit almost
did man I'm just not having luck
today oh gosh o o should we yeah he sees
your ghost man if I was I if I saw a
ghost of a dude who was taking people's
balls i' probably be you're in a tight
spot this could be
interesting you're in a tight spot
you're free balling y looks like we
going go for it
yep that is Elite right there
yes kill or don't if if we were to
restart this area would you have a
couple more shots from that perch yes do
that do that do that okay do that I
swear to God maybe this says all I all I
care about this video game but all I
care about is just seeing some someone
get yeah here we go Danny I think
regular viewers of the lobby know where
your priorities lie oh please God take
his balls I feel like that's
intesting oh yes wow that was pretty you
explo he had two grenades for balls that
could be the only explanation well his
balls are definitely gone there we can
say that yes they are no I think he can
get one more I think he can do it you
want to restart it or try from here
whatever you need to do yeah you can
restart need all right that was perfect
perfect spot let's try to get it might's
very quickly I will say the reloading
time on this does make me want to play
it more because it means you can just
keep harvesting balls right it does
do it new house does load very quickly
all right try he's so far away lower
oh not getting with that guy you're here
yeah try that try that
dude if this was the farest be really
hard to shoot their balls off don't even
know they don't even have them they need
their kend
dolls that might be it that might be
good he was crouched you are getting all
sorts of crazy right at the waist every
time I'm not I'm not I don't want to go
on to the next section of the show until
you get a ball get a ball get on I can
hear voices in my ear but
no oh my god look got that guy
yeah it's not happening reload reload
get yourself give yourself in one more
shot okay we're going to do this maybe
there's someone closer than that guy is
there someone else there's a there's a
guy right got to you just got to think
and put yourself in the mindset of
there's a dude right there right there
look at him look where is he right he
just for geten off look you can even see
where his butt is in those not very form
fitting lower where are you aiming I
don't want to there like right at
the you were those get those guys full
on kidney Styles here we go here we go
no scope baby no scope ball shot it's I
mean he's looking through a scope yeah
load it again again Lo it again load it
again all right the twitch chat has
spoken they want their balls uh-oh uhoh
I loaded into come on high
alert oh he's on the run in Motion in
motion ball shot this is the shot you
were born to take man it's really not
wanting me to get the
balls come on oh we might have one here
come on come on come on that was pretty
low just please don't
explode oh intestin though you did get a
glimpse of them I got to see some you
got a glimpse is that enough to satiate
your ball lust D no the all my ball lust
is just even more ravenous now I've seen
so you've got a taste and you want more
this is getting out of hand yes reload
reload intestine shot what intes shot
reload I'm loading into an a high alert
situation now it's fine get that guy
yeah he's an
idiot all right is a guy over there
no he's he's behind the bullet protector
oh my goodness
o
o oh that's going to be something
I'm hoping his balls are tucked up into
his over his pants arm arm
bone oh oh
yeah oh my God out the ribs I don't know
if you're going to get it vious one more
chance one more this is the Olympic this
is the World Cup final of taking dude's
balls do it I believe in you this is
your
shot
USA
run all right wait for it
let the balls come to you look there's a
guy to the right of the tent he's fairly
stationary let the balls come to you
this is going to be tough he's in a
Crouch position there's a lot of stuff
down near his balls come
on you do it show me the test no no
that's
Ines a wow wa there he didn't any balls
that was not an he didn't have any balls
anally correct there listen hey look I
didn't know so many of these
there's there's a plurality of human
physiology out there is this the unic
Brigade shoot that guy shoot that guy oh
you had it you had
it the pressure it's too much proving
too
much Chris you've got one shot Chris one
shot one shot reload this is Sniper
Elite version 3 it's out on a bunch of
platforms PS3 PS4 Xbox 360 oh what is
this it's not inverted I can't and
windows you play inverted yes we're
playing this on a what's the button
again is it R RB to do the slow down
stuff um yeah RB or press on the left
stick oh my God this is very
challenging okay it's you got someone
sneaking up behind you too I don't
care stand up you fool do it stand oh
they got that guy in the
background oh you're getting murdered
from behind I am he's taking your balls
oh my goodness oh oh well
gosh uh I'm sorry guys well that's you
know you you win some you lose
some you lost this one Nut N nut shots
zero fired fired y get out you had a
good run buddy I'm just going to be
taking this right here I'll be honest it
might be a slow week next week we might
we might have you back on to try and get
even more nut shots I I'll try my best
Alex new thank you so much for coming on
thank you guys showing us some German
balls even if they didn't get exploded
pretty we'll be back in a moment Uh
Kevin vanor is going to be on to show
off some new Divinity a new Divinity
game divinity the original sin it's like
the seven Divinity game and I know so
little about this Kevin knows all about
it so stay tuned also we're giving away
those what you don't
really also we're going to we're going
to give away a bunch of uh World of
Warcraft uh Warlords of drain or codes
super soon so stay tuned back in a
second from the most realistic players
ever created in a FIFA title to fully
realized Arenas with living pitches this
year we brought a whole new level of
visuals to the game one of the first
things you'll notice in FIFA for 15 is
just how authentic players look to their
real life
counterparts our overhauled lighting
system vastly changes how players appear
creating a much more natural environment
and a true to life look and new
character models and body rigging will
make players feel powerful and athletic
you'll also notice incredible new
features like visible breathing and hair
movement you'll see kits move
realistically and visibly get dirty with
both mud and grass as the match unfolds
on the pitch itself boots and slide
tackles will now leave marks on the
grass and as the match goes on the
playing surface becomes increasingly
weathered just as it would in a real
match in wet weather games rain spray
and Davy will kick up off the turf as
players battle for the ball stadiums
will now include animated LED boards
Corner Flags will now move and go frames
will rattle if a shot smashes off the
bar or lift off the ground if a strike
will rifles R into the back of the net
incredible visuals is only one part of
the FIFA 15 story subscribe to our
YouTube channel to see more upcoming
Innovations including emotion and
intensity and player
control sports that's a thing that's
maybe Happening Now show hello welcome
back to the lobby we're going to give
away to those cods pretty soon don't
worry about it keep watching what's
going on Sports
Denny hey how's it going over there
buddy I don't know together maybe I'm
watching something else I don't know
it's not it's going to hold just hold on
okay no we're good we're good we're good
okay we can talk about all right all
right all right Co no wait we need to
keep talking on our single shots no what
we need to do is to create a mystery
about what's happening next what could
possibly be happening I don't know oh
Kevin manard Kevin hey are we live
what's going on but what we do is first
we introduce it we have to introduce it
properly for all the on demand versions
so that's when I go right oh yeah yeah
hi cool should we do that so Divinity
original sin okay well they did they cut
there so I got to do it again cuz then
the cut happened this is how the sausage
is made hello welcome back to the lobby
did you know there's a new Divinity game
out Kevin vanard does that's why he's
here to talk to us all about it well
hello Divinity original sin yes it's a
much better name than Divine Divinity
that really irked me that it is was
isn't that still the name of like a
power in that game though that's all
right yourself against Divine
Divinity it's been a while since I
played the original Divine divid it's
been it's been it's been years but you
can play it on Steam now which is good
you can now get Divine well you could
get it before on GG as well but you can
get you can like get Divine Divinity at
a sequel Beyond Divinity yeah and then
yeah well yeah and then Divinity 2 came
out and that was a different kind of
game a third person sort of uh action
RPG original sin is different as well
because it's they're kind of leaning
into the yeah oral completely different
and you play as two different people as
well a lot yeah at one time so so Chris
is oh Chris is getting me already going
yeah look at thats really good so for
folks who don't know anything about this
Kevin uh what type of game is Divinity
original all right so this is a this is
an isometric view roleplaying game um so
at first you know at first blush you
might think hey this looks a whole lot
like Diablo um but it's not actually
like Diablo at all probably think it
looks a lot like
Diablo shush Diablo shush your pedantic
mouth Yes Kevin so so you start with
your two adventurers and this is the
very very beginning of the game I'm I'm
beyond this but because of where I am in
the game I suspect that it would be
really boring to show that stuff off so
this is actually the beginning so at
first blush yeah it looks a little bit
like it might be like a Diablo kind of
thing or Diablo
or um but instead it's it's a lot more
like Temple of Elemental Evil if you
ever played that so you get the top down
thing but once combat starts what's it
doing here it actually goes Turn base
okay and I'm hoping to show you that but
first i'm going to come over here pick
up
a scroll maybe pick up a a shell pick up
those you always cuz you've got the
warrior and then your Mystic which is
kind of like your healer do you always
control the warrior you can control
either one okay so e and either one has
different uh you know different
socialization skills so it's not like in
you know in in conversation it's not
just defaulting to you know it's whoever
you're controlling at the time you can
switch between them um and there are
reasons to switch between them so for
example my witch she can talk to
uh she can talk to animals so sometimes
there's a reason to switch over so if
you click on it with the dude he's like
why do you ask me to talk to his animal
for I can't talk to animals yeah they're
just like meow right does he say meow
and then it's like oh nothing well no he
doesn't say meow but she it it's
actually interesting because there's one
part towards the beginning of game where
you're talking to wizard there we go so
here's battle so as soon as battle
initiates you get you get into a turnbas
deal godess be with you Master turn
based yes all right is it all right so
they're running in they're initiating so
they're running there's going to be one
guy that's left if I recall correctly
he's going to do a summon drawn from
blood skeletons I beat you
golems and boom there you go or so all
the combat is turnbas so the combat is
all turn based although you can do
things that are sort of combat oriented
even when you're not in combat like heal
each other or attack doors and things
like that so fight is beginning and it
tells you you can control and and find
out attributes over these things so
right now you know it starts with my
witch gets the first turn so she's got a
lot of different things that she can do
it's nice you start with like a good
variety of spells it's not like blah you
know like a lot of RPGs you being like
Oh I can do the one thing so the first
thing range attack and then I can learn
area attack is I am going to
summon your own skeleton I'm going to
summon a spider oh sick so the first
thing that happens is she like boom oh
gross there's a gross spider for you it
looks really good like you yeah the
game's very good looking spider already
now she preserves two action points her
her she's done moving on to the spider's
turn so I'm just going to go after the
summon ouch I love that animation like
crazy where go and the twitch shot the
twitch shot wants to the twitch shot
wants to know how much ball physics is
in this game there is approximately no
ball physics
disappointing well you know we have to
have a diverse show here Danny we have
to have it this this appears to arachn
files uh testif files we already appear
appealed to in our first segment and
then later on you know Warcraft
something so let's uh let's do some
other magic let's do this uh sort of
magic Missile here as showby 89 asks do
you have a main character or a bunch of
characters these are the only two
characters you actually play as right
you don't customize add more characters
to your party you'll eventually come
across people that like you know Hench
people that you can add to your party
and whatnot they're all fully
controllable they all have their own
inventories and so on and so forth two
at a time always so no not two at a time
always you you get more okay so you get
up to do you know how up to was I I
don't know I I want to say it's probably
four but I don't know don't don't ask me
they all have the dialogue options you
were talking about earlier yeah you
always have yeah exactly you always get
the dialogue stuff sorry I get I get
distracted easily we're asking you a lot
of questions know there's some dialog
stuff coming oh that was a really close
magic shot that you did there Kevin uh I
like how the magic how it's like uh
snakes it's not just a straight line
Arrow it kind kind swerves its way in
there so it's interesting as I played
some of this game when it was an alpha
but I did not actually play you know any
of the any of the later stuff after the
alpha in like January this was
Kickstarter right yes this was
Kickstarter um they got over a million I
think and they asked Asos for about
400,000 nicely done and what they did is
they made a really what seems to be a
really good game so far um I'm still
early times obviously I'm beyond this
early time this again this is the this
is basically the the introduction stuff
but
uh things get really really interested
so so this is where you can like oh I
can attack this but you have to be
really careful when you choose to attack
stuff in the environment because your
your stuff takes uh takes damage okay
your weapons your weapons take Dam more
so than you should be used to it can
happen really fast especially if you're
be very careful with uh especially if
you're like a rogue using daggers or
something those things can break really
fast H Bob man88 asks is there a co-op
mode in this oh yeah yeah you can
totally Co-op and it has really
interesting conversation things that you
can do um hopefully I'll get a chance to
show you that just in the single player
bit
because there's there there's actually a
rock Pap yeah you can move stuff around
this looks a little silly visually Force
Power I like it but that's kind I mean
like having that does that lead to any
kind of I mean removing an obstacle is
one thing but does that lead to any kind
of exploration or puzzles totally in
combat you can use that stuff like if
there's a a barrel of oil then I can
throw that on the floor and spread oil
and then I can and then I can throw a
candle on top of it and set it a
flame and you'll actually I think you're
actually going to see that soon so
there's apparently a mine ahead um so I
have to come up here I can't see there
it is H completely unrelated this game
is made by lar and of course who've made
all the uh Divinity games uh and they're
located in Belgium so uh just you know
totally Belgium huh Belgium yeah I hear
that's a okay Nation for people with bad
opinions about stuff no that did not
seem to be a real safe way to Def was
mistake that I I me you're on fire I
meant to cast a spell with her and I
failed I wasn't thinking you just cered
it with your St I did that was pretty
embarrassing
uh yeah g wenner asks is there Friendly
Fire did we just answer that question
there yes there is friendly fire for
sure yes absolutely I'm going to drop
that scroll in there um surprised you
managed to deflect that damage that was
a close one and if you don't want you
can do something like if you don't want
them to stay together like that you can
if you want to control them individually
you can just drag their their uh
portraits apart like that and then now
she'll stay seate yeah and you need that
puzzle solving anywhere in the world oh
really
wow you can be completely separate
that's especially handy in Co-op if you
want to separate with with your uh you
know from your from your partner and go
and do different things what have you
thought still do that what have you
thought about the story so far Affinity
is asking is the story as well thought
out as right now I'm just about the the
story like it's just whatever you know
it's sort of like oh you're you're going
to the village and The Wizard there
summons you and you have to solve a
murderer kind of thing and that's that's
in the main story that's all I'm doing
right now because I'm really distracted
by the sudden glut of things that I get
to do and there's a lot of exploration
because this is not a game that holds
your hand this is not a game that
sometimes a little too it expects you a
little a little too much out of you to
figure out how stuff worked like how the
weapon damage worked and how to uh how
to repair it uhhuh it took me while to
figure out actually how to how to do
some of that stuff you were saying
earlier like the characters you find
there is no in terms of customization uh
before you get them can you make your
own characters or is it can you
customize your characters once far as I
know only the two at the beginning the
two that you make at the beginning are
the only ones that you can customize as
far as I know the rest of them are all
just in-game characters you kind of run
into exactly so far exactly and then
there loadouts and gear and stuff like
that like inventory wise is there much
you can do yep yep there's here's a huge
inventory and you get between characters
and if you need one character to have
another thing you actually have to
switch it between the two s did you say
his name was Hugh no his name is R huge
inventory huge inventory the Hugh
inventory that would be great can you
name him Hugh if you want you can yes
you can I I went with the default names
which are rodri and Scarlet but you can
use whatever you want and in this case I
need to get past that door did you go
into the the skills and talents were
there as well what's in there oh yeah
yeah what else we got so uh over here
we've got so here is just the regular
it's all the regular stuff if I move
over here you've got different weap
abilities defensive ability skills all
of your stuff under personality
excellent um and a and when you make
decisions you can cuz your your two
characters Nast Deeds yeah nasty Deeds
which would be lock like uh not
murdering people stuff like that and
then there are talents um like this that
eventually you get Talent points like
right now he's an opportunist which
means he gets to perform additional
attacks of opportunity this guy gets uh
you know gets a maximum action two
points when his health is low what's
Escapist do do you
Rite
es it's it just turns you into YSI
Escapist allows you to flee combat even
when enemies are right next to you what
about Far Man uh far increases the range
of spells and Scrolls by 2 meters so you
get a little a little extra there so at
this point I need to I should have been
paying attention I'm going to need to do
something with this door probably bash
it probably bash that door uh so given
that that land mine earlier I mean this
sort of seems like it's a high fantasy
kind of setting but a landmine isn't
exactly like swords and sorcery type
domain no
like does it sort of cast The Net wide
in terms of uh what kind of gear and
what kind of world this is like how much
is is technology you know in in a more
modern Sense part of this world it does
have some elements of things that you
might more associate with like you know
kind of Steampunk whatever and it
teaches you to quick save so I might as
well just do what it says right just in
case and but it does cast its net a
little bit wide but it's mostly you know
tolkien-esque fantasy so here's an issue
where it's like okay what do I do here
I've got uh I've got all this fire and I
have to pass well just so happens
there's a rain scroll over
here so I'm going to pick up the rain
scr hello stick that down oops I missed
stick that down here and now I'm going
to cast the rain on top and this this
comes I believe the term is Make It
Rain so I will he's not a strip club
Chris so for example if I'm in combat
and I'm on fire I could do this you know
to or if you're fighting some eph would
that like damage them maybe yeah and you
see over here just in case there were
water barrels I could have just thrown
it on there if I had enough strength in
this case you can't use those ones
combat a started I'm guessing the yeah
you can use all that stuff with comat
still move stuff around you can still
fire arrows at stuff and attack things
in the environment and stuff yeah
totally that's cool H oppression X 805
asks will this be on Steam this is
already on Steam this already on Ste
yesterday I think yeah it was launched
yeah it yesterday was official launch
and the thing is that oh I can sit down
you want to see some sweet sitting down
AC $9.99 this is almost as good
chat not no chat just yet although we we
will hopefully chat soon I just
that that world like disappearing as the
camera moves in this is pretty good
that's pretty great yeah they have you
like that effect yeah I'm into this so
in this case it's like oh I need to
unlock a door so I guess I'll just uh
try some nasty Deeds on it try some
nasty Deeds you know I like those nasty
Deeds if you level up your nasty Deeds
can you like perform them at a greatly
reduced
cost what do you mean reduced costs like
you have to if stuff normally is
expensive can you do them dirt cheap
yeah took a little while I get jokes but
I got
it that's pretty good how much have you
played this so far totally get jokes I
am like uh I'm like maybe uh 6 hours in
or something like that but I feel like
I've done nothing I'm seriously at the
point where I feel like nothing has
happened so here the world is vast or
because you find it tedious because it's
vast and there's a lot to do and in a
few cases because the game doesn't
necessarily help help you figure out
stuff so there's a lot of time spent
like just hey how do I how do I do this
what does this do yeah how do I you know
what do these what are these people
going to say okay so now but are you
finding that entertaining or are you
finding it tedious are you turned into a
stone I think it's entertaining it's
it's stealth mode so here's stealth mode
now when you go into stealth mode you
automatically leave your partner behind
with apologies to Solid Snake and and
here's a fun thing I'm just going to
throw some candles on
them on these mummies yeah they because
see they've got they've got oil on the
ground and so I'm going to catch them on
fire well they seem pretty non-perturbed
by the fact that they're on fire right
now momies man they's not I'm going to
come over here and see if I can if I can
do more of that oh nope all right so I'm
coming back I'm coming back I'm coming
back that is really delightful does it
say the The Rock on the side of that the
the orange the gray rock all right so
here we go I'm goingon to I'm going to
do some summoning I'm just going to do a
bunch of summoning let's summon what
kind of stuff can you summon she already
had a spider at what are type of animals
well there's this here uh skeleton I had
a scroll so you can use anybody can use
a scroll um there you don't have to have
learned the spell in advance or anything
so she's done now here comes my
fighter
so let's do this uh oh he's got a summon
in here too I think do it yeah summon
wolf summon wolf so let's summon the
wolf dire wolf
it oh oh my goodness what an amazing
save so cool that wolf that was
incredible yeah you like that wow yeah
he's pretty great that was really yeah
and now my summon has his turn but he's
not going to be able to quite get there
I have enough action points though where
he can attack this dude so yeah you miss
great doofus he miss too than skeleton
oh he got you there oh God here comes
the second guy
all right now we've got her let's get a
spider in on the axe yeah horrible
spider
demon that makes a bit more sense cuz
you're in a cave earlier it was a bit
weird we just kind of dangle down I know
I kind of like it I like the air drop
spider yeah pretty much pretty much
and done all right Wolf's turn let's see
what the wolf's got up his y f do up do
wolves have sleeves Dam he's immune to
bleeding but it's okay cuz he's dead now
right take that mummy I don't I can't go
over there so let's kind of come over
here I find most people are immune to
beating once they've died so Kevin the
the turn based stuff here doesn't take
place on a hex Grid or anything like
that do you find you run into any kind
of uh path finding or like like resource
you know cuz like every move every space
you move takes up you know it'll take up
some points to move do you do you find
that all that sort of balances out and
you can get a good sense of How It's
like
the logic is sound and the and
predictable and so you think you can
move somewhere you can move there do you
do you get a good sense of that totally
totally it works there's there's a
little bit of this issue where it's like
how close can I get before fight
fighting starts um that kind of thing
before you initiate the turnbas segment
exactly but once you once you kind of
get used to that you can kind of you
you're still using the environment to
how you kind of want to use it for
yourself you just got to pay attention
to what you see what's happening around
you cool and then it all it all sort of
works out on its own it's it's it's it's
pretty easy to to pick up on Kevin thank
you very much for coming on you're done
I got one more question for you one so
good that I just want to keep playing
this game well people can pick it up for
themselves it's on Steam right now 399 H
when is our review going up who knows
it's I guess it's a big I just started
it we didn't get Advanced code of the
final version so I got I got started
when everybody else gets started so as
soon as I'm it's it's done when it's
done it's like a blizzard game cool I
got one final question because it was
something I was wondering as well
Evermind 88 in games spot chat asks does
the game scale with your level or do you
do much grinding the as far as I know
the game does not scale with your level
okay you're not going out there and it's
this is not Oblivion or whatever you
know it's like if something's high
powerered and you go out there and you
face it it you're you're screwed
excellent you know and there are places
where you can get into really really big
trouble cuz you can fight anything you
want to fight if you want to or steal
anything that you want to steal people
will not be happy with you they will
attack you you can attack um different
you know different Mission givers so
that you know their their side missions
are now Gone Forever you can you know
there's is there any a good reason to do
that though I feel like you always want
the mission off guy looks at you wrong
there's a good well a lot a lot of this
stuff the missions just there's so many
different ways of completing them like
the fact that I can talk to animals has
made certain instances quite different
than if I couldn't like I get Clues and
I can suddenly like I can solve my
murder a different way everyone talk to
animals if they play these characters if
they play a a witch
start or
you choose that um when you get the
opportunity are you also reviewing World
of Warcraft expansion packs as well no
all right no well you you're not we will
have that on the show post taste as well
it's funny cuz it's the big MMO guy in
the office that's the one MMO I don't
play really yeah fair enough we have
Justin hay well on pretty soon to show
us some of that Madness we're also
giving away a hell bunch of keys for
that stay tuned we're going to give away
just a few minutes first of all Mary
Kish I hear there are some new video
games coming
out hey was up Mary defitely me Mary oh
my gosh not a fake one no you were here
last week oh yeah I forgot I forgot I
was there you were all
discombobulated it sounded it looked
like you were on drugs though I think I
I didn't get a lot of sleep and um I was
on acid so H tell us about new games
while we look at something that isn't
what you're doing for about 20 seconds
we're going to be pay talk to the
audience about uh new re-releases at
Danny and Chris Waters watch soccer no
no there's
nothing they're not even going to be
responding I'm playing some Divinity
Divine I'm watching that's not even a
game you make that up I'm wearing these
glasses cuz they make me look dope and
no other reason Super Fresh this you do
look dope no you look like a dope I mean
oh God no you look like a dope Divinity
that's not that wasn't the right screen
you'll notice behind me uh this isn't
accurate all these games come out today
on the first uh so that's pretty much
the only thing you should be aware of
misleading graphics with Mary K I I
didn't make these I think I think
somebody made these before I got here I
was on vacation last week it's not my
fault sure Rob was here it was probably
his fault you were here roll let's roll
the footage that Rob made it's not my
fault so guaca melee this is the super
turbo Championship Edition it's 15 bucks
this came out uh today on the 1 um just
kind of like more levels and I heard you
can you can come back as the chicken and
there's even like explosive eggs in the
chicken not too bad I'm sorry I'm
looking at like you're listening I'm
looking at Gundam Dynasty Warriors
Gundam reborn uh this is also out today
uh and you get to play in space wow
that's a very dramatic setpiece position
for you to play in oh my God what a time
for the video to they had a
really creative meeting where they
decided that they would do it in space
screw it let's put space V lovers child
of light is on Vita today uh it's a
fantastic fantastic story I really
enjoyed this I think it's worth anyone
you like the rhy yeah it gets a little
old uh still liked it I like the combat
is really cool did you guys have your
sea legs no I do I vomit regularly on
boats new game about shipping great ship
yeah does it have a thing where most of
the people in your family have died in
their profession you B it it does I
almost got there good you almost landed
that one it's free shipping I had a
dream that I was on a boat the other
night it was it was a big boat that that
doesn't make any sense are you guys
still watching the game what game video
games watching video games Warlords of
dror no Julio's just getting it set up
uh so all those games are out now for
video game people to to buy and not
everything you saw is today uh except
for Divinity original sin that was
yesterday so it has no value it is the
same so they're all out now so you can
go get them thanks very much Mary you
know what also out all the games I spent
my Goddamn money on in the Steam Sale
last week I got did you spend a lot of
tiny bucks to end up spending big bucks
I spent a lot I got uh I got next car
game finally that was pretty good am I
giving them free advertising I got next
car game finally nicely done that was
pretty good I like that uh we're going
to be back in a moment we're going to
give away a bunch of uh World of
Warcraft uh codes as well so stay tuned
but right now random question with our
good friend Timothy
schaer oh um maybe uh I would have
change that um that part where you kick
the wall and Full
Throttle made it
into not kicking a wall not kicking a
wall
still z00 don't worry about it hello
welcome back did you know that World of
Warcraft is still kicking along I do
because I've been going to a sport group
uh since I quit about four years ago
every day since they keep priming at
those expansion packs Warlords of dra or
Justin it is it is just to give you the
worst possible entrance into this
segment really nailed it there
buddy it it is a game that that is hard
to give up um used to be uh part of a
guild back in the old oneup days is
called can't quit you I can't quit you
Guild that's pretty good but Julio here
has been putting a lot more time into it
we we talked about this on a live stream
yesterday Warlords of dror is coming out
soon I think we might be giving away
some codes we are in fact before we
start this uh I want to let the good
Folks at home know that they can get in
on this right now if they go to get a
tab ready you ready all right
gamespot.com SL wow giveaway go to that
page right now and then you can get
access to the beta for you're very self
we have a bunch of codes we are not
that's the smallest Link in the world I
love it it's tiny if you're watching
this on your phone I'm sorry just type
wow giveaway it's not even that hard
yeah it's pretty good fourar giveaway I
believe in you we've got Bunches of them
nobody else knows except the people
watching this stream so just get in
there now H get your beta code and uh
yeah we're going to we're going to show
it off right now yeah and you'll be able
to play exactly what we're doing here so
the way they've set up the beta is that
you're able to to actually just create
your own uh level 90 character like you
don't have to go through anything
because we're just testing it right
Julio yeah yeah they give you one level
90 uh when you buy the game and uh well
since it's beta we can make as many 90s
as we want um is that the level cap no
100 yeah so so if you play through the
the previous expansion you can get up to
level 90 and to make sure that players
are able to you know start experiencing
the the new stuff that they made they're
going to give you a level 90 when you I
mean give you when you buy the game you
can have one character that's set to
level 90 and one of the interesting
things they they're adding for this
expansion is the ability to buy more
level 90 characters like you can pay
it's like 60 bucks right that's annoying
I hate that that's BS that's Absolut
bive blizzard should be ashamed of
himself why is it worse than just giving
them a free level 90 it's because you
can stack More Level 90s that you didn't
earn anyway let's Deep dive I want I
want to get let's get into it what's new
in wars of drain or why is there
something that I want to go back and
play again oh my goodness that is a big
bulll okay the most notable thing that
you know people are going to notice is
the uh new graphics right new character
models new models yeah it's is it only
character models or they uped any of the
environments whatsoever uh well they're
making a new world right dror yeah which
is basically what outlands was before
became outlands yeah so that's all brand
new uh but this is I guess a much bigger
deal I actually made a video on this can
we roll it yeah yeah we got a we got a
video on this B boy oh what comparing
old and new yeah here we go going to put
a video in your video all right stop
covering your face so we can see your
face all right there you go so it's
harder to see the comparisons I think
when you're just looking at the new
models but when you look at them side by
side there's there's a distinct
difference between the the way these
characters previously looked yeah that
was a really exciting uh offthe line uh
challenge by this dwarf uh in the last
minute of this of this gameplay demo do
we have any other ones yeah yeah let's
let's keep going on these bad boys this
is a tiny person I want to see less eyes
got bigger less dwarves and more uh more
big old models the faces look more
details yep when when you go in close
you can see even more more changes but
yeah everyone has his full screen right
now now that you're seeing all these
animations yeah there you go so there
are still more characters yet to be
revealed with their you know their
updates um the game has doesn't have a
release date you know we're assuming
it's going to be sometime in the fall
and before that they'll show off how all
of the new character models will look
okay that orc does look more
MUSC yeah definitely looks more badass
less polygamy polygon but everything
else looks the same like there's no like
new ass Stormwind or Iron Forge or no
the world it's the regular world that
you'll be visiting is pretty much much
the same I don't think there's going to
be a huge overhaul yeah that no that
would just take way too much well for a
game that came out if I'm right it was
2004 right so like a decade ago it's
it's it's looking all right still no
it's looking pretty good no they made a
they took a gamble going with this art
cartoony art style and they were panned
for it so much in the beginning but in
the end that's really paid off like that
this holds up better than a lot of more
realistic looking games that's actually
a really good- looking Tor yeah look how
much better that looks the old one looks
so bad okay let's hop into the game
we've had enough of that Co get IR for
there we spent some time with this uh
the other day yesterday kind of playing
around with some of the the new starting
area but uh there's some new things that
they're introducing to this uh like
Garrison some new things that you're
going to be able to play around with but
you don't get to jump into those right
away okay the first things that we
played around with are they're pretty
similar to the rest of the wow that
you've been playing like you know kind
of explore to be honest this is the
while everyone remembers where are we
now for folks who don't know this is uh
this is what you or okay in burning
Crusade this is hellfire Peninsula dark
portals right here right so in burning
Crusade this area is all like destructed
and red and it looks completely
different right now I guess oh my
goodness ah that Panther jump is just
really can't believe how this is right
yeah you remember how Hellfire looks
like wow no totally this is hellfire
this this doesn't look like Hellfire man
there's all grass growing around and
stuff like that do you know who remember
what Hellfire looks like in it Jurgen
Clansman yeah oh definitely cannot
believe it and and so in this game
you're actually traveling backwards in
time so this isn't like a different
version of this world this is actually
that that original part of the world but
thousands of of years ago is everybody
Benjamin buttoning that's nothing new to
uh Warcraft uh that happened in BC as
well right I remember when they started
doing the well outlands I guess was that
traveling two time technically or that
was traveling to a different place day
no there was the what did they call them
the um instance um oh those Time stuff
what was that yes oh man so long oh yeah
getting to experience moments of the
past but this is literally being in this
entire world like you're experiencing
the world in basically the way that it
was back then and for people that have
been really into the game it's probably
not something that's going to draw in
new players but getting to experience
that lore firsthand that people have
been reading about or skipping over
whenever you get a a new Quest cool if
anyone has any questions by all means in
the twitch chat Gamespot chat um we'll
stop screaming about other stuff now for
about a 5 minute break but don't worry
about it I think that's actually
something going on right now awesome
iname awesome in-game event happening
dude you just got 20,000 XP did we just
like yell where that event at uh-oh oh I
think that event is happen to right on
your head this is the event all right
let's get hit you are getting
evented this is the Event
Horizon run to the docks I'm just going
to sit here listen to him sit on your
butt take a drink Julio you are so
contrarian all right let's go get to the
docks so what else have we got new in
here even if it's stuff that we can't
see so explain um the new uh Garrison
and stuff like what are you upgrading is
it one for yourself is it one your clan
can have are you upgrading buildings
that exist in the game world what's
going on so at some point within the
within the Warlords of drain War
expansion you're going to be able to to
build a garison which is basically
building a house it's not something new
to MMOs but it's something new to to
World of Warcraft and one that's been
asked I think since the first expansion
p and and this is a place where you'll
be able to get quests you'll be able to
to build it up and to make your own
individual house bigger and stronger be
able to to add things that you wouldn't
have access to in other parts of the
game do you know where that lives like
surely in some instance nowhere world
right you can't just plop one down in
the middle of the Elin Forest be instan
but I think you can have it in different
parts of dror you get to choose where
it's at so that it's one of those things
that you can see but not of course not
everybody can see it because that would
just make a ridiculous world but you can
invite other people to it so it'll it
kind of like the the way that the world
deforms around you as you complete some
quests um you see a different version of
World of Warcraft than than other people
see and that's kind of how your uh how
your Garrison will live you'll be able
to invite other people to it and you'll
be able to see it when you're walking
around we're assuming but other people
aren't going to be bothered by having
your enormous in the middle of their
place was that awesome world event just
a firestorm to get you all to run to
this dance party oh here we go yeah I
barely noticed the meteor so it kind of
just rode my Panther over there it's
pretty Majestic Panther is this sort of
uh the camera taking cinematic stuff is
this this is an in-game cinematic I'm
assuming they're going to add audio
later right is that stuff new I haven't
played the past expans cinematics yeah
yeah that sort of stuff no not really
yeah they've been doing this for for the
past few expansions okay well one thing
that is interesting is that you lose the
ability to fly when you come out to this
version of dror which is pissing a lot
of people off um is it it's people are
split I think I think the more hardcore
people are are happy with it because
you're going to meet a lot more people
out there in the world yeah when you're
not up in the sky you know flying by
yourself so I think that's all right it
just depends I I think they're not
completely set in stone on whether or
not they're even going to allow flying
in Jor oh really it feels like
eventually they are that's going to be
something that unlocks again but it's
it's not going to be for a while that
would be kind of ironic considering
that's where out Outland was where you
first learned to fly right exactly but
it does get you closer to the ground get
you you you see more people cuz when
everyone's flying then yeah and I
imagine it's harder to make a world
where you're able to fly to everything
because then you just fly like you don't
you don't try walk you don't explore
anything you just kind of fly from one
point to the other kind of feels like
you wouldn't be as motivated to make
like a nicely winding path with like
well placed sh
if you know everyone's just as the crow
flies but at the same time once you lose
flying like it's it is so freeing and so
much more fun to to fly from one spot to
another CU it's so much faster going
back to to just traveling on the ground
feels slow Justin just likes not getting
killed there in the sky right I play I
play PVE I don't have to worry about
that H there's a bunch more content as
well I know there are doing the usual
shake up of dungeons new dungeons uh
these mythic raids as well are they just
like really really difficult big part
raids oh man those bad boys are really
what are Mythic raids so apparently
they're much more difficult raids but
I'm not sure if they're like 10 party
difficult ones or if they're like large
difficult ones sure it's not heroic I
don't know app new
on I don't know I know they've had
heroic before that are that are you
making up adjectives
so one interesting thing from this is
that this is part of the a larger plan
to to release more regular content like
they they haven't said specifically
we're going to do this every year but
they have hinted that that's part of the
plan or at least one of their ideas that
they're going for is is if not yearly at
least really really regularly instead of
having patches like normally when an
expansion like this comes out there'll
be a significant patch that comes out
eventually which adds more content adds
more things to do and instead of having
a big patch they're just going to go for
for a full out expansion because that's
the thing that that brings in new
players and gets people excited it's
also the thing you can charge a bunch of
money for and have midnight launches for
and I worked about four or five midnight
launches uh for w stuff um over the
years and they always get a hell big
bunch of people queueing up uh for these
like it's do you think that they would
still do that at at this point I mean I
feel like World of Warcraft more than
anywhere is a digital download Spot like
when I was playing certainly and like
and the folks that ice to play with
having the physical like think about it
blizzard are one of those companies that
still like massive limited edition
versions like Diablo and stuff like
games that people are only ever going to
you know like they probably have the
same problem with did you go to the
midnight launches back in the the day
yeah yeah I used to work on oh that used
to be awesome used to be fun I still get
those big limited edition boxes just cuz
they're they're so nicely done I don't
usually buy a limited edition of a game
but for the World of Warcraft ones I I
usually World of Warcraft and Starcraft
and Diablo like they're just those big
heavy boxes I like putting them on you
have yeah do you have a shelf spot you
keep them on they look kind of nice all
in a row they're adhering to the same
kind of form factor but different art I
appreciate that they're the same every
year you don't have to worry about like
suddenly one has like different form
they've got your number hey W big time
when is Warlords ofor out for everyone
so we don't have a date it's sometime in
the fall but you know usually this hits
before BlizzCon and you know we're
thinking that if they want to do the big
raids that they they normally do at
BlizzCon this is going to have to hit
before then so you probably expect to
get into this for everybody to be able
to get into this uh before before
BlizzCon at least uh the the beta keys
that we're handing out you do need to
have M of panderia already installed so
this okay this is not going to be
something that you're just able to oh
grab a key and if I haven't been playing
World of Warcraft at all for a while I
can jump in you do we found out you need
Mr Pandaria okay to play it apologies to
anyone who I didn't say that to
beforehand um but yeah I do have Mr
pandas I bought it like I buy every
expansion pack and then played about 10
minutes and then forgot I had it
installed and haven't played it against
us so thanks you're welcome blizard is
this going to bring you back in seeing
every single expansion P comes out I go
back and play a bit of it but I haven't
had a proper hook on any of them I think
cataclysm was the one that I went back
and played for a couple of months again
um maybe four or five months but I have
I don't know what do you think it what
would what would bring you and keep you
back into a game the thing about why it
makes me not want to play it is that I
feel like I'm wasting time that I could
have been spent playing newer de
different games so I don't know anyway
anyway I believe it's extra time in the
US game so we're going to get the hell
out of here so we can watch the rest of
the game thanks to everyone for tuning
into the lobby this week thanks everyone
on the back thanks to these awesome
dudes where's my flag where's my flag
thank you than you guys for watching
gamespot.com wow giveaway if you want to
get in on the Warlords of dror uh beta
here if and you have Misty Pand oh
no oh Belgium you suck what God I don't
have Mr pandar that's why I'm so upset
about the thing that just oh if only you
had myths of the P all right
everyone univision.com
we'll see you
there see you next week thanks for
hanging out in the lobby
adios stupid
belum